hey hi everybody thank you for okay
let's figure this out
we good
okay we should be good now hi everyone
once again thank you for the
introduction
and we'll be starting and before we
start I want to ask you uh two questions
how many of you are uh familiar with the
field of causality
so it's around 40 50 okay
um how many of you are familiar with
deep learning
learning like most of you okay
perfect
good to go how many of you are familiar
with the directed acyclic graphs
okay
so we will
we will do it for both groups for those
familiar and not familiar great
um let's start with with an example
so imagine you have a friend she's a
researcher in some field whatever the
field is
and she comes up with an idea
that addresses a long-standing problem
in hair
research area
okay some novel
it's a novel solution to a problem that
people are trying to solve for a long
time
and she publishes a paper
now
let's call her Jane
you have another friend whose name is
Jay Jake
and Jake reads Jane's paper
uh
he publishes another paper that builds
on top of her discovery
and adds a couple of ideas but they are
not that novel they are not that
revolutionary as her ideas are
and they do it in in a very short time
period
now 12 months passes
and Jane's paper gets
573 citations
but Jake's paper
it's
977 citations
so it's almost twice
twice more
now there might be many reasons for this
so maybe they have different
affiliations and Jake's affiliation is
better more popular
maybe they publish in different journals
maybe they have different writing styles
and Jake's writing style was more
compelling to the readers or maybe
easier to understand
and there might be
more
more factors like this but one factor
and there's a research like this a
potential Factor can be James gender
so there's a research that is showing
that papers that have offers who are
easily identified as female by their
names for instance
are cited less frequently their than
papers by the male counterparts
so now sometimes
we might be interested
in answering a question if gender could
be a factor here
so was it about Jane's work
something like a journal something like
an affiliation or maybe about her gender
or to be precise the perceived gender
right her perceived gender how people
perceive perceived her gender
so we can ask a question like this
holding everything else constant would
Jane have been cited more often had she
been perceived as being male
and this question is a counterfactual
question
and we ask those questions
and similar questions in the
field that is called counterfactual
fairness
and this is one type of questions that
the intersection of causality and NLP is
trying to tackle
there are more questions we'll see other
possible questions in a in a second
and before we go to to the middle of
this presentation let me tell you five
words about myself my name is Alexander
molak I love struggling with my wife
running and I enjoy good vegan food for
the last six years I was helping a
Fortune 100 500 and Inc 5000 companies
building machine learning systems
uh and I'm currently finishing my book
on causality and machine learning so if
this is something that is interesting to
you you can scan this QR code and get to
a page and subscribe for the updates on
the bookend also
for a newsletter we've curated causality
related content
Okay so
how are we going to structure the
presentation today
so we'll start with an overview what is
causality
for around
around 50 percent of you this might be a
little bit boring but I'll be asking
questions so you'll be maybe we'll have
an opportunity to have some fun
then we'll talk about llms and causality
what's the connection and we'll start
talking about the large language models
that are popular today
and give an overview
um
of the intersection of how they work and
how causal they might be then we'll talk
about two streams of causal NLP
then we'll introduce the the
architecture we work today with called
causal bird
and finally we'll have some time for
questions
okay so what is causality
this is the definition that Wikipedia
gives for causality has understood in
physics causality is the relationship
between causes and effects
what are your thoughts about this
definition
is it a good definition
I'm pretty sure we have opinions
bit
a bit large so not specific that's what
you mean
okay
yes it can be the relationship may not
be
true
the relationship may not be true so what
you're saying is that this definition
does not say anything important about
the relationship itself
yeah we are testing the relationship
maybe but we don't know yet
okay great thank you
any other voices
yes go on
does it really set it apart from the
correlation a very good question
leads to the effect
so what you say is that this definition
is not very precise when it comes to the
direction of this relationship
circular I also think so
so circular in definitions means that it
defines the term causality using the
term cause that likely is defined by
using the term causality
so it itself
referential yes
you would have a treatment and you could
look at that and then also have several
factors that are like kind of
like some other
not counterfacturers but
co-founders you could look at that and
that would make it
mm-hmm so what you're saying is that it
only talks about causes and effects but
doesn't they talk about other elements
that could be involved in a system that
could modify this relationship is that
correct great thank you that's these are
all great they're all great
um great ideas and great comments what I
what do you think what causality is
and this can be about intuitions don't
worry if it's correct or not it's it's
more about understanding what are your
intuitions
so like around 50 percent of you said
that that you have some experience with
causality so under some understanding so
let's get some let's get some intuitions
maybe from the people who Rose their
hands or the other half
okay I see you want to say something
don't be shy no no not really okay
okay anyone yes
so he said it's about quantifying so
causality is is
um
about quantifying how one element
influences other elements that's what
you're saying
on the one hand okay
and coming and coming up with ideas what
could have influence on something else
so that would be discovering causal
mechanisms and the first part you
mentioned would be about just
quantifying the strength yes strength of
of effect okay that's great
um do we have any more voices here
or here yes
mm-hmm finding the real root cause of of
the effect yeah that's that's very good
how could we do it how could we operate
operationalize those ideas both the free
ideas that we that we heard about
how could we easily Define it
an experiment could help us
so experiment so what would be an
experiment for instance
an A B test
so intervening on one one parameter in
the system and looking what is changing
in the system right
thank you that's a that's a great
intuition and this is very similar to
the definition of causality that we will
use today as our main definition that
comes from Judy apparel and this
definition says it's a very simple
definition so maybe even embarrassingly
simple but I think it's beautiful
because of its Simplicity and it states
a is a cause of B if B listens to a so
this is what you said about a B test we
change something we intervene on the
system
it's a it's it's a targeted intervention
so we only intervene on one aspect of
the system and we observe how other
elements in the system in this case b is
changing
prayer also came with uh came up with
something that's called the letter of
causation for those of those of you who
are not familiar with this and he said
there are three ranks on this letter
first is Association so this is
everything
um
that we quantify statistically
purely statistically there will be
correlations that will be dependence
by saying correlation I mean linear
correlation so dependence would be more
complex relationships between between
functions or objects
um
then we have intervention so this is
what we just what we have just discussed
so we change we tweak one element in the
system and we observe how other elements
in the system are changing and then we
have counterfactuals and counter
factuals would be like doing in a sense
like doing an intervention but in the
Imagine world
uh in pearls
in Perth teaching each of those ranks
has a separate mathematical set of tools
that allows us to talk about those rungs
okay
so we will see that in association we
can we can use purely statistical
statistical language for interventions
we will need we'll need something as do
operator
okay then do operator means that we are
changing something do operator can be
expressed purely statistically sometimes
not always
and finally for counterfactuals we have
another set of
another set of of notation
an important aspect of beryllium
causality are directed as basically
graphs so these are graphs where you
have nodes you have directed edges
so there's always an arrow which
signifies the
direction of influence
and they are acyclic which means that
there are no direct Cycles nor indirect
Cycles which means that let's say this
is perceived gender this is style this
is number of likes
for a Reddit post Maybe
so
there is no path in this graph there
cannot be a path in this graph that goes
from perceived gender to itself it can
be through other nodes or directly
if this is if this condition is met the
graph is acyclic
and we will make use of those structures
today
okay why model causality
how to increase the number of
non-commercial space launches per year
so there are probably many answers to
this question
one answer
that is a data-driven answer
is to increase the number of phds in
sociology in the US
this answer comes from the first rank of
the ladder of causation so Association
and it comes from this data that was
collected by by Tyler vergan
that's one of the on the graphs of
graphs on his side on his website and as
you can see the correlation between
those two
so non-commercial space launchers and
sociology doctorates in the U.S are very
strongly correlated and this correlation
is strong over
more than a decade
so you can also see this
you can also see this as a scatter plot
maybe that's less impressive I don't
know
and so
this answer most people would say that
this answer increasing the number of
Sociology doctorates in the US is not
causally related with with space
launches right most of us would say so
most likely there is a common cause to
this so maybe in those years there was
something happening in the global
economy that was influencing both both
variables or maybe maybe some other
mechanism
and now this leads us to to an
interesting conclusion
when we think about the when we think
about the state of
contemporary of modern NLP
we can all we can often hear people
talking about models hallucinating what
does it mean that the model is
hallucinating
language
so the model so we will ask the model to
do something and the model will invent
this on on the Fly that's that's right
that's what you're saying yeah okay
but now one thing is that we don't need
large language models to experience
hallucinations from from a model and
linear regression will be for will be
enough for us
which means that a very simple model
that we can use that many of us probably
have used in the in the past
can actually give us results that are
hallucinations
and this comes
almost directly from
from the fact
that we often mix the ladders the ranks
in the ladder of causation
so let's see let's see why
let's imagine a fire alarm system
and in our world we have just three
variables fire smoke and alarm
and the alarm
will react to smoke okay so this is one
classifier alarm so I'm not an expert on
this but I checked it
one class of fire alarms that react to
smoke particles so they have smoke
detectors
and they
and they set off when when the smoke is
detected now
symbolically we could express it this
way so we have fire that causes smoke
that causes alar
an interesting fact about this
is that fire
in the alarm
are independent
given smoke
which means that if there's smoke
the alarm will set off
with some probability if it's a
probabilistic system or if it's fully
deterministic without errors it will
just set off
and it doesn't matter if there's fire
okay so we can imagine a situation where
we just open the window and there is
fire outside the smoke is coming inside
and the alarm
and the alarm starts
now this property is not a property of
alarms only we can
we can generalize it and it will work uh
for for any variables so if you have a
variable a causing B and B causing C if
we control for B
a and c will become independent
okay because the the only dependence or
the only variability that c has in
common with a goes through b
do we have any questions here
no okay
now this structure is called a chain
it has its name and now if we think
about
different structure the structures that
are possible with three variables
we'll get two more
so we have a fork
will be
causes a and c and what will happen if
we control for B
what would be the dependent slash
Independence pattern here so in the
previous one we said that
if we control for B A and C we will
become independent but they are
dependent if we are
if we are not controlling for B so now
we have the second pattern which is
called a fork what will happen if we
control for B will a and C become
dependent or independent
they should be
dependent if we control if we don't
control
we should expect like some relationships
happening
[Music]
so so what you say what's your name
said that if we change something in B
then we should expect some differences
in a and C that's okay but if we don't
if we cannot intervene on the system if
we only can observe it now think about
statistic statistical control we we
observed these three variables okay and
now if we look at the correlation let's
say it's it's everything is linear very
simple if we look at pairwise
correlations would a and C B
uh be dependent or independent without
any interventions
do we have any guesses here yes
after controlling forbid they should be
independent and without controlling for
B
iOS
they theoretically they could cancel out
yes but that would be very rare but
probably in real world I learned like
yes so this is a very good answer so
controlling for B A and C will become
independent but if we are not
controlling for B we are just looking at
pairwise correlations they will be
dependent most likely very likely
and so now the the independence pattern
between
chain and within Fork is the same right
so
if we control for the middle variable
it renders the
the variables on the left and the right
uh
independent now the Third
structure is called a Collider
what will happen if we control for B
here
okay so collider is very special
because we've Collider the pattern is
reversed
so we have two causes a and and C that
are causing B
and if you look at correlation at the
correlation coefficient between a and C
or any any other measurement of or
metric of of dependence
a and c will be independent pairwise but
if you control for B
they will become conditionally dependent
okay you can think of it that
controlling for B enables the flow of
information through this variable
this is the least intuitive one I would
say but it is very important in
causality
so the difference
between these behaviors between collider
and both chain and and a fork
makes causal Discovery possible but it's
also crucial in causal inference because
if we control for a wrong variable in
our system
we can actually
enable information flow in the system
that is not real
okay and we'll see this in a second
in the regression analysis
so what I did here I took three
variables a b and c
I generated those variables according to
those three patterns that we have seen a
chain a fork and a Collider
and I run an analysis
of a predicting C controlling for B
and as you can see for chains B is a
significant predictor of
see
but a is not
okay so if we haven't control for B I
would be a significant projector for C
but if we control for it
a becomes independent
the same as you suggested the same
happens for for a fork
B
is a significant predictor of
C
but a is not
but for Collider
the pattern is different both are
significant when we control four
five significant value we control for B
so to see this in practice let's do some
coding so we'll need five steps for you
to open the environment you can do it in
your computer or we'll also do it on the
screen so you don't have to
so go to bitly slash Pi data Berlin 23
and this should open a GitHub repo
then you need to copy the address of
this GitHub repo
something wrong here wow
that's so bad
hmm
I guess with
it might be case sensitive yeah is it
okay good thank you
so this is case sensitive you need to
say Pi with capital data capital and
Berlin capital letters
okay
have it then you need to copy the link
from the from the browser when the
repository when when you open the
repository and then go to collab
research Google
.com
and then
choose GitHub there will be this window
and paste the link and click the search
icon
and then it should open the GitHub link
for you
now trying to oh okay
oh that will be difficult but
I only see this here
okay does everybody
has anyone needs uh needs some help
no okay
okay so you can run the first cell it
will install some stuff
before you do it you can change you can
make sure that you have GPU
run anyway cancel
[Music]
is it here
I changed
can you help me the GPU now
this is if you yes yes thank you
it's terrified
okay so we can run this code
and we have some stuff random seed and
so on
and then we have data generating
processes okay
so let's see if it's executed it's still
executing
okay so first we we build a DAC like
this and dag stands for directed
basically graph as we said we have X
causing Y and we have W causing X and Y
so you can see that there's a structure
here
what is the structure between x w and y
we had a collider focal chain
this is a focus exactly so it's a fork
structure
so now
statistically speaking
X and Y if we remove this path and this
is a fork X and Y will be still related
for this path
right because we said that in a fork if
we don't control for the middle variable
the variables on the ends
will be related so now if we run a an
analysis
and we don't control for w
then our estimate of the influence of of
X on y will be biased because we will
have this influence here on this path
the true path
but also there is there will be some
influence going here
so we need to control for w in order to
get an unbiased
and unbiased estimate so let's
generate some data according to this
graph
and run an analysis
okay
so what we're doing here is
we say that W is some random Vector okay
X is caused by W and some noise
and Y is 5 times x
plus 2 times W plus some noise okay
now we run linear regression
this is stats models API
and we can look at the coefficients
we can look at the coefficients
and you will see that the coefficient
for X is 4.99 so it's almost 5.
the coefficient for w is 2.007 something
so it's almost two it's almost exactly
they're almost exactly
the coefficients that we designed there
this also shows us that linear
regression can be interpreted causally
if certain assumptions are met one of
these assumptions is that there is no
hidden confounding which means there are
no more variables like w that are
causing both X and Y
if we are sure about this linear
regression can be interpreted constantly
okay let's see the second data
generating process
the second process is different
now we have X and causing y
and both X and Y are causing W as well
so what will be the structure between x
w and y
we had a chain a collider and a fork
again
yes exactly that would be a collider
that's a very good answer so there are
both
they are both causing w
now if if in this analysis because we
said before
Collider
has in has an in has an inter
conditional independent structure that
is reversed comparing to force and
chains
so now if we control for w in this
analysis
let's see what's happening so first X is
some random noise okay Y is 5 times X
plus some random noise and W is 5 times
x but still times y plus some random
noise
so we expect that
the coefficient for x will be five but
it is
-2
oh this is pretty far away
there's also some coefficient for for w
which doesn't make sense because
W has no influence on y right but if we
go to the wrong one of the ladder of
causation which is Association it makes
sense because they share some
information there is some variability in
Y and X
in in W and W sorry w and y that are
shared and it's shared because they are
related but the direction of this
relationship
causally speaking
is reversed
then what we see comparing to what we
see here
so as you can see our linear regression
is is hallucinating now right
there's a there's a strong positive
influence of X on y
the coefficient is five but the
regression tells us that it's minus two
okay
do we have any questions here or
comments
okay those structures do you feel this
is clear
yeah yeah
um why is always like your output yes
okay yes yes so so x x is the the
treatment and Y is the output and W is
some additional information
great any more questions
no okay so so it seems we have Clarity
regarding this
good so let's go back to let's get back
to the presentation
and let's talk about large language
models so where are we today with
language models and causally speaking
one of the examples from my book
uh
in the chapter on counterfactuals and it
goes John has
coffee sensitivity he drank coffee in
the morning and his stomach now hurts
okay and the question is would his
stomach still hurt if he had not drunk
the coffee
so in the book we have a formal
treatment of this of this example we
have a set of equations and we show how
we can retrieve counterfactuals in in
certain cases purely analytically but
here we just asked chat GPT to answer
this question for us and so Chad GPT has
no his stomach would not hurt if he had
not drunk coffee assuming that his
coffee sensitivity is the only cause of
his stomach ache if John has a
sensitivity to coffee then drinking
coffee can cause adverse reactions in
his body such as stomach pain therefore
it is likely that the coffee had drunk
in the morning is the cause of his
current stomach ache if he had not
consumed the coffee he would not have
experienced this specific reaction
what are your thoughts about this
is
even the information
so you say that this seems to be correct
especially that that the model also
gives us this restriction that as
assuming that this is the only cause
I agree with that I think this is a
really impressive answer and before the
chat GPT
that would be
You Could Only Hope For answers like
this from from large language models
that we had previously
but you know as they say hope is not a
strategy
um
this is one of very good answers like
very good causal analysis a very good
causal answers that that I got from chat
GPT when I was testing it early on for
causal questions
I was very impressed by this here we
have a tweet from Judea Pearl who was
also doing tests lately with chat with
gpt4 and so on and so on and
and he he gave like a set of examples to
the models some of them were some of the
answers were correct some of them were
incorrect
but it seems that many people got very
good answers and
but this is not always the case so
now I gave the model
the description of the of the graph that
we've just seen the one with a collider
and I asked to determine and I asked if
we should control for w
and the model set to determine whether
we should control 4w in the model that
seeks to understand uh that seeks to
understand the impact of X on y we need
first examine the relationship between X
Y and W and then it gives
um
a long explanation
and it concludes therefore to understand
the impact of X on W and isolate its
effects it's advisable to control for w
in the model
and it says this is because the
variation in y that is explained by W is
not due to X alone but also to the noise
and the contribution of Y so this is an
argument
that seemingly sounds
very reasonable because it says there's
some variation in y
that we can see in W but we cannot see
it in in x
and so if we want to make our estimator
reduce the variance of our estimator we
should control for w
but the problem is that W also opens
the path between X and Y and as you have
seen it changes the coefficient
essentially
in an arbitrary way so you can get
effect where there is no effect reverse
sine and so on and so on so this
argumentation is incorrect
and there are more examples like this
so there are essentially two papers from
last two weeks the first one comes from
the Microsoft research team from Chong
Chang and and the team that works on NLP
and causality there the second comes
from technician University to darmstadt
from moist Village and matiz and and
their team
and they both go they both present
similar conclusions and they say that
the large language models
might give us good causal answers
sometimes but they do not understand
causality
by default
moreover
the theme from from table darmstadt
proposed a very interesting formalism
where they say that the model is
actually learning
a structural a metastructural causal
model
strictly from language
so an interesting research was performed
by Amit Sharma from Microsoft
he took a a
famous causal data set that is called
tubingen causal pairs you have pairs of
two variables
and this data set is often used to
Benchmark causal Discovery algorithms
and he passed the questions about all
those pairs to chat GPT and he got
accuracy of 97 percent I guess if I
remember correctly
and the best state of the art algorithms
go up to 83 Maybe
yeah so that's a very good question so
the question is if we know if it was
trained on this information so as they
say here in this
lengthy description
the model likely was trained on this
information right so it had information
about the connection of altitude and
temperature maybe it took it somewhere
from Wikipedia or another source and the
same is most likely true for other pairs
and this is the conclusion that the
researchers from downstairs do
make a
that the model is learning a causal
model of the world but strictly from
language right from statistical
dependencies in language and they call
it they formalizes mathematically uh in
a pretty elegant way
and they call it a meta SCM
they also say that they
proposed that those Foundation models
those large language models
might be exploiting a loophole in the
causal hierarchy by Pearl so CHT it
stands for this letter of causation and
so on and this is very very closely
related to another research by Michaela
Vander Shah and her lab
where researchers proposed rank 1.5
which is between Association and
intervention so sometimes we might have
models that might give us
a useful useful causal information but
without theoretical guarantees
and they have a very interesting Matrix
when they where they put static and and
time sensitive models and so on and so
on
so the conclusion of this is that
although those causal all of those large
language models can be helpful regarding
causality we cannot get guarantees from
from them at this stage and some of the
proposals for the future work are to
combine those models with implicit or
explicit causal modules
where model can
where model can use a module like this
to get computations about causal
relationships and then translate them
back to language and and return the the
output when you say a module do you mean
something like the flag and stuff like
that like it outsourced something I
don't want to be a library which does
that it like interacts with the library
the library checks its reasoning and
then the model Converses that
so so the question is what do we mean by
modules is it about a library yes
exactly so so that's one of the that's
one of the solutions proposed by uh by
Zhong Chang and and and the team they
say that there might be a like a causal
module a library some code that performs
causal reasoning for us and then the
model translates it back to natural
language and and Returns the output for
us
okay
so
the large language large language models
that that we have today they are not
causal by default
so what can we do with with NLP and
causality
there are basically two broad streams of
research
the first one
is about causality and real world
so that would be about questions about
those altitude cause changes in
temperature or the other way around
does gender cause
articles to be less cited or more cited
or perceived gender
anything like this so any relationship
that we have in the real world
and the second stream
is about
causal
influences within the model itself so
what would have happened if we change
this embedding
what would change if we rephrase the
question and so on and so on
so we will focus uh today on the on the
first one
on the real world questions
and they're basically four scenarios in
this uh in this category
the first one is text as outcome
an example of this could be that we
perform an educational program
and we want to check if this educational
program influenced
the readability of the text that
participants are producing
okay so maybe people are writing essays
then we run a program and we want to
understand if this program has impacted
the readability of those essays produced
by the participants
the second
the second scenario is text as
confounder confounder which means a
common cause something that can cause
the treatment and cause the the output
as in the first
example that we've seen in the in the
notebook today
and here uh we could say how perceived
gender affect affects number of
citations so the so the example from the
beginning
and I built a DAC here because this is
not that intuitive at least I I did not
find it that intuitive in the beginning
so here we have perceived gender here we
have topic of the article
that is uh that can be
operationalized as an abstract so
abstract has information about the topic
and we have a number of citations
and here we have gender
the true gender not perceived gender and
then we know that gender might affect
the distribution of topics at least in
today's society
and it also affects the perceived gender
and so this path
if we don't control for gender here
this path is
um this path is open
so we could control for gender or we
could control for topic and any of those
nodes will close the confounding path
and finally we have not finally but
almost finally we have text as treatment
so maybe the way how the way we
communicate
influences someone someone's choices
for instance you could think about
a use case where we transcript
cycle therapy sessions and then we want
to see
how the ways that therapist is choosing
to communicate translates to the
outcomes of the
um of the client
and that's finally text as mediator
how does perceived gender affect number
of likes mediated by writing style okay
so we have
this direct effect here
and here we have also mediated effects
so we if we want if we are interested in
so-called natural direct effect
so only this
one Arrow here we should control for
Style
but style is
hard to Define right so we can take a
model
build embeddings
and then maybe we can
maybe we can try to train or fine-tune
this embeddings in a way
that will emphasize
the relevant parts of the of the text
okay so let's talk about an architecture
that is called causal Bert
this architecture has been introduced by
Victor of age
and and colleagues in the article called
adapting text embeddings for causal
inference this is an article from
20 or 21.
and the basic idea here is
that we take a large language model
in the original work it was Bert in the
implementation that we'll be using today
it will be distilbert so a slightly
smaller architecture
then we perform some modification on
this model okay
we'll talk about this in in more detail
in a second
and we want to predict eight so-called
eight stands for average treatment
effect
and is defined as
a difference between counterfactual
outcomes
so counterfactuals we talked about
counterfactuals briefly in the beginning
two counterfactual outcomes we say that
we have we assume that we have a binary
treatment
and so this is the expected
value of the outcome under treatment
and some other variables relevant
variables minus the expected value of
the outcome
given no treatment and the same set of
variables
this and this equation is for continuous
variables but for uh
this can be also for we can also say
this is probability or this is a
distribution this is the distribution
and do it for categorical or binary
variables or anything else we want
um
now what's the problem with this
so we said we we take
the outcome under treatment and the
outcome under no treatment so what what
was what's the what can be problematic
here
so the answer was it's hard to estimate
because we either have treatment or we
don't and this is uh so-called the
fundamental problem of causal inference
that we only observe in the real world
we only observe this one outcome
so either somebody took a pill or they
did not
and as you said it's hard to estimate
because now we essentially
need to
think how to
build this alternative world
in a way that is still realistic
so how how do they approach this
so they they propose a model that builds
that builds three different
artifacts
document level embedding
which is just in regular embedding in
within the within the language model
then we have a mapping from the
embedding to propensity score what is a
propensity score
you said that this is the likelihood
that the treatment is assigned in a
binary case yes yes that's a good answer
so this is the probability or sometimes
likelihood that uh
that given
a set of values for X for our variables
the treatment is assigned to this this
particular unit
and then we have mappings from embedding
2D outcome so this model learns those
three things
and it does so in a way
that goes like this
so we have this distal bird
um
then we learn embeddings
like traditional so this is MLM stands
for mask language model what is a mask
language model
mm-hmm
is that we it's about supervised
learning where we don't enabled so we
try to
get labels by just
moving
words or sequences or from sentences and
then
yeah perfect thank you exactly so so
Mass language model is this is this
is this objective that we use
that we use in training large language
models when in unsupervised manner we
just remove or mask certain tokens and
then we are trying to predict those
masks tokens given the context
and this is how we learn the embedding
and now we use this embedding
to estimate the expected value of
outcome given treatment and the
embedding
the expected value of outcome given no
treatment and the embedding and finally
the propensity score
as you mentioned which is the
probability that the treatment is
assigned
given the embedding
there are a number of assumptions for
for this model
for those of you familiar with causality
there won't be probably surprising so
first one is no hidden confounding
which means that we have this graph x Y
and W causing both of them
we observe all
all the nodes W in in the in w
then we have positivity
what is positivity
probability of
being treated
it's the positive probability of being
treated given a set of variables that
those variables take a given set of
values
thank you and finally no leakage slash
consistency
who knows what is consistency or no
leakage
I I cannot hear you can you say
okay I could not hear you I will go to
you
all possible values of control are also
present in the treatment data set uh
that's that's positivity
that's a very good description of
positivity in other words
consistency is slightly different so it
says consistency is a more complex thing
but let's go focus on on no leakage this
means that the treatment by one unit
is not influencing uh the treatment for
another unit okay so if we say this is
treatment for you so you get the
treatment but if you did not get a
treatment you are not influenced by hair
treatment
okay
if you have any questions here
regarding the assumptions
okay so let's do some coding let's go
back to let's go back to the notebook
okay and we will use uh
you will use the implementation
from
from prison from Microsoft
who who implemented Coastal bird using
pytorch the original implementation was
in tensorflow
which I I actually wanted to use
tensorflow to implementation but I had
some challenges uh with running it in
collab so we'll run this python staff
this is not available as a library
but as a repository so you can say
causal you can type causal bird pytorch
in in Google and you should find this
Repository
and then we will import
the data it's called test data and it
comes from
from read present as well
and as you can see this data has four
columns so this is text
just a free text then we have treatment
we have confounder indicator
and we have outcome
and the outcome is binary and this
implementation only works for binary
outcomes
okay so let's instantiate the model
this wrapper is like very high level so
we don't need to
so we don't need to do too much low
level coding
and as you can see it's downloading
downloading the model from
uh from hacking face
and what's inside you can see that this
causal bird from pre-trained and causal
but if you look into this class we'll
call distal bird
and then use pre-trained distal bird for
um for training now we have a bunch of
parameters here so let's let's go
through them we have batch size
which is about size that's a very
self-explanatory we have G weight Q8 and
MLM weight
so those weights are waiting the cost
function in the training
see
is propensity score
this refers back to the original paper
when they call when they call
propensities called G which is not very
intuitive Maybe
if you familiar with the literature but
this is what they do Q is the embedding
Q is the embedding
um
embedding under treatment
so I wanted to go back to the
presentation
sure that will be easy okay
so G is this thing we're trying to
estimate the probability of treatment
given the embedding
then Q are those two things so the
probability or the expected value of
outcome given treatment and given no
treatment
and MLM objective this is the
traditional objective
for
the embedding model
and now those
all three of them has their own loss
components in the training
okay
so the influence
of the embedding
you can decrease it you can you can
basically weight them you can balance
them you can make
The Mask language model objective more
important less important than so on so
the offers in the original paper they
conclude that that using must language
model
is
is beneficial they also compare it to
other approaches like bag of wars and so
on
and so these are the default values
proposed by by presenting his Repository
now if you want to use this in practice
and my recommendation would be
if you can afford this to split your
data set into training and validation
and try to find Optimal values for those
those losses empirically
okay
so now
we can train the model
there is a train method in the in the
total Trapper we take texts we take
confounders treatments and outcomes
and we Define the number of epochs we
want to train for
yes of course
where we see one
of us yes could you explain
yes I read that
yesterday yes yes so that's a great
question so while it's let's see if it's
training it's training okay so that's a
great question the question is what
exactly the task is
so this data let's talk about this data
for a second
so this data comes from read present and
I don't know its exact source
these texts are about music
so these are might be this might be
comments from some subreddit or maybe
another online forum
now we have we have some treatment here
which is Maybe
in a similar data I'm so first of all
I'm guessing a little bit because this
data set is not documented anywhere I
wanted to bring you another data set
from like a real world problem but
unfortunately was impossible so that's
why we're using this one but now similar
data sets very similar data sets usually
are structured like this so text is some
text from maybe an online forum
then the treatment is maybe if people
have specified gender in their profile
description
the outcome will be maybe a like or a
lack of like
or I don't know if somebody reposted
this anything like this some action that
people take
and then confounders here will Mark the
we might Mark the confounding content in
the text
okay
does it answer a question
so confounder is something that that
influences both the treatment and the
outcome
now if we had this um
so let me let me let me show you the in
the diagram I think it will be easier
yes I I think that's this is how we
should interpret this this particular
data set yes
so some action
so for instance
[Music]
so for instance a
yeah so we have gender here
then we have perceived gender that is
coming from the I don't know your
profile description or your icon
and there we have some
we have some outcomes some use user
action
and then we have and then we have text
and maybe this text is influenced by
gender as well right because maybe
people differ culturally or I don't know
whatever or biologically in some way
that that influences their their choices
of of the topic and then we can have
then we can have maybe other confounders
um
maybe there is something more in your in
your profile that is also influencing
your perceived gender and and the user
action and then we can provide a
categorical variable sorry categorical
variable that will mark this type of
confounder okay maybe in this in this
particular implementation we can only
provide a categorical variables so that
would be like one two or one two three
four five and so on discrete values
so so this is arbitrary it can be
anything that do you think is a
confounder in your in your setting
anything additional to to the text
maybe a profile picture yeah maybe a
profile picture or maybe yeah maybe
something else in your description
so if we had this example X and Y X
causing Y and then we had W so w doesn't
have to be just one variable it can be a
set of variables
no this is text as confounder but they
might be also different confundles okay
it might be like a broader set of
confounders
make sense
those really
so you can have you can have like two
variables that are causing the treatment
and the outcome for instance
so that could be a profile picture for
instance I think this is a good very
good example
so we have text but you also have a
profile
profile picture so profile picture will
influence your perceived gender because
persons people will say like hey it's a
girl on the picture it's a it's a guy on
the picture and there it will also it
can also uh influence the outcome
because maybe people find you attractive
right and they will be more likely to
to click a like under your comment or
repost it
but the text of your comment also is
also important I guess
you know Finding or confirming these
other relationships is what we want to
find out but like
deciding this particular thing is
yeah
so that's a very good point now in
causality we usually talk about two
broad categories of of tasks so one is
causal discovery
which is about discovering
hopefully as automatic as automatically
as possible
causal relationships between variables
and then we have causal inference which
is just quantifying those so everything
we talk about today here
is about causal inference
so we had this idea one of the
assumptions was no hidden confounding
right this might be a difficult
assumption but if you assume that you
know all the confounding variables
um well this this these methods will be
helpful for you if you say like I have
no idea maybe there's like 500 other
confounders
then the results of this
will be highly
it would be highly risky to use them in
in practice
does it answer your question yeah
yeah
in reality we are gonna in reality we
are going to have a lot of confounders
so should we have to include all of them
in the model
so the question online was in reality
we'll have a lot of confunders so should
we include all of them in the model
that's a very good question
often we are not able to exclude all the
confounders if we want those methods to
work and have all the guarantees that
they might have some of them have more
some of them have less then we should
include all confounders in the in the
model
now
from my practice in the industry
I can tell you that usually
the process looks like this that you
start with some model
with your best expert knowledge that you
can gather all over the place
then you build a model
then you generate some data from from
these models and predictions from this
model and then you compare this to some
new data
and then you iterate and you improve the
model
so this is usually the process that that
I see in the industry and I also
recommend
um because in many cases especially when
we talk about like open-ended complex
systems like I don't know social media
um
whatever social topics and so on it will
be very very hard to control for for all
confounders now another way to work with
those methods is to run experiments so
if you are able to run an experiment
an experiment will actually will will
basically
cut where is the treatment here so the
experiment you can think about running
an experiment as cutting off all the
arrows that are coming into the
treatment in the graph so we are
removing this Arrow by ironic and
experiment and by experiment I I mean
randomly assigning perceived gender
in this case your treatment
and now your data is unconfounded
if you if you run an experiment
so hopefully that answers the the
question
do we have any more
not yet okay good
okay let's get back to the model and see
and see if it has trained
okay it's finishing
so put two epochs here it might not be
enough
or it might be enough
okay so the training has concluded
so now we can take the
it can take the model and it has a
method called Eight ate average
treatment effect we pass the confounded
syntax and this will return the average
treatment effect for our data set
right so we are doing an inference task
not a prediction task
we are all we are we are checking the
average treatment effect on the same
data set
mm-hmm
Etc all these four scenario and what is
this so this is Texas confounder as well
this is Texas confounder and this method
can be also used for text estimated
mediator
but as far as I as I understand
this particular implementation it only
works for for Texas confounder
to give an example again once again for
text as confounder Texas
no that will be uh just let me
okay
so now text is is an abstract of I don't
know abstract of a of a paper okay
and
there is this path between gender
and abstract
that uh that opens the path between
perceived gender and and number of
citations
so if we control for for topic we'll
close this path
and now only this path remains which
means that we now have the effect of
perceived gender of numbers of citations
but if we don't control for this and we
don't control for this and I assume that
the real gender is unobserved here
then this path is open
and this will change the estimate uh for
for this effect here
so anytime so anytime you you can you
can think of
um
text influencing like your treatment and
outcome this will be text as confounder
why my treatment yeah why your treatment
why would influence my treatment well it
depends what your treatment is like
anytime anytime it happens it will be a
confounder
now of course it depends it depends on
what your treatment is but it might it
might depend it might affect
your treatment
I'll try to think about another example
when this is happening and we'll try to
give it to you if not now we can try uh
to talk after after the talk
yes
yes I don't know I find it a bit
confusing I think the terminology of
treatment like it doesn't mean that you
it's an interview to change it it just
means that it's just an episode yeah
yeah that's a very common so the comment
was for the people online that the
treatment doesn't have to be I don't
know a drug or something or something
that can be just just one of the
observed variables that you are
interested in the effect of this
observed variable another on another
observed variable
so there's a strong connotation about
the treatment being something
being something that we manipulate or
like something hard or and so on so this
might be useful for for some people
thank you that's a very good comment
okay
and so we
so we have it and the average treatment
effect
here is minus point 22
the thing is that
uh and this and this is pretty the thing
is that this is pretty stable I run this
I run this model like I don't know like
a dozen of times and it was always
a very similar to this so maybe
-25 minus 24 minus 22.
um
which is a very good sign
so let's go let's get back to the
presentation
okay so a couple of conclusions from the
from the paper language modeling helps
which means that the offers have tried
also using different different
approaches
um if I remember correctly they're using
bag of wars and and this other stuff
um and some other stuff I'm sorry and
language modeling in terms of using
language large language models helps in
particular when we adapt those
embeddings to learn this more complex uh
objective function that models
counterfactual outcomes and the
propensity score
also another thing is that custom
pre-training helps so they notice that
not only uh
let's take a step back what happens when
we train this model
we are in so-called fine-tuning regime
which means that we're taking
pre-trained embeddings and then we are
learning our objective function starting
from those pre-training embeddings
what the offers suggested here is that
before we do that
a good thing to do
is to
take your data and run a couple of runs
of unsupervised pre-training using this
data and they noticed that this also
improves the
improves the estimates
again again
yes
yes exactly so the question was should
we do it in right in the same way as if
we would train a large language model
from scratch using this must language
masked language model objective and the
answer is yes so I think that's exactly
what they say you start with the
pre-trained model
but you still run just the mask language
mask language objective for a couple of
runs using your data set and then you do
fine tuning using the method with the
complex loss function that we that we've
seen in action today
do they explain why
so the question is
yeah so the question is why this is the
case so I think this is uh
something that is
that we often see in the industry that
when you adapt a model to a new task for
instance I used to work at iron skills
which is a cyber security company
and we're training large language models
on uh to predict certain qualities of of
emails
you can imagine that
email language might be slightly
different than General language on the
internet the distribution of EMS might
be slightly different than the
distribution of overall language on the
internet
and then
not only fine-tune fine-tuning this
model for
for for our classification task but also
training this on this email language in
particular before we uh train the model
on a task might be beneficial because it
makes the distribution that the model
learns more similar to your domain
distribution
Does this answer a question yeah
perfect
again again
read about the theory interpretation
that
so the question is about the theory that
llms are simulators no I haven't read
the paper like this but I can imagine
that you could probably say this about
any generative model to an extent
the better the word model you have the
better your own prediction
those are probably the symptoms
the language
so the comment was that if we think
about large language models as
simulators the better representation of
language we learn the better outcome
outcome we can we can expect and we can
also learn more specific things like
personas you said right and so on and so
on and this and this is likely related
also to the observation that the offers
had had here
okay so we conclude here and if you want
to learn more about uh causal inference
and natural language processing this is
a great paper by Amit feder from
technion in Haifa and and his colleagues
from like all over the place as you can
see
um and this is a this is a great
overview
of work in on the intersection of
causality and NLP I also have a QR code
for you here so you so you can make it
you can just make it like this yeah
okay we have more questions good
once again how often
different what
dag configurations that configurations
and explain the observed data
uh that's okay so the question is how
often we we test for for the structure
of dag
uh so that is the directed icically
graph that's a very general question so
in the sense it's hard to answer uh
but it's good to test for this right uh
maybe let me take a step back there are
different use cases so so so far we are
talking about like social models that
are trying to model so some social
phenomena
and these are often open-ended and
complex systems and in this sense it's
very difficult or might be very
difficult
uh to exclude all the hidden confounding
or control for all the hidden
confounding but not all systems are like
this so for instance there are very
successful implementations of causal
models in the industry where you have
for instance systems like production
lines
that are virtually almost closed
and so the influences from the outside
are very limited and often those systems
also are well documented when it comes
to
when it comes to how information in
those systems flow so this might be
might be very very different case but if
I if I had to give you like a general
answer well I would test to the extent
where I feel this model makes sense and
fits the data well
I know it's broad but I guess
that's the best one I can give in in a
general sense
so there are some studies stating that
propensity score performed poorly to
decrease the imbalance between control
and test do you also use Alternatives
such as Mahala Nobis so so so it says
that there are studies that show that
propensity score can
can perform poorly I'm not sure which
studies the person asking the question
is referring to there are certainly
studies that showing that propensity
scores are a very bad choice when it
comes to matching so matching is one is
another type of of an estimator that can
be used in causality but matching on
propensity scores can lead to a very to
very detrimental results so
um
so this should not be done in other
cases I I don't know perhaps there are
studies that that also show some
problems with propensity scores in a
broader sense
but but I'm not aware of the of of those
and here in this work uh people usually
usually usually work with propensity
scores if anything
so in the case of text as outcome or
treatment scenarios how would you
quantify the ate since the tax is not a
numerical variable that's a great
question so the question is in case of
text as treatment or outcome how would
you quantify ate given that text is not
a numerical variable so
in general we've seen the formula for 80
that is for binary variables and in our
case the outcomes also also binary but
it doesn't have to be the case
um
so
we can have continuous treatments and
continuous outcomes as well that's the
first thing the second thing is that
if we treat text as as as
outcome we might sometimes just say hey
if there was some feature in the text
right so maybe if certain set of
features in our embedding space has
certain values then we just say okay
this is one otherwise it's zero so it
can be binarized sometimes and
and also it can be a continuous variable
when it comes to the treatment it can
also be a continuous variable moreover
it can be a
multi-variate variable in a automatic
dimensional variable so we can have an
embedding space
perhaps
perhaps cast down to some lower
lower dimensional space like I know
maybe we have eight dimensions and these
eight Dimensions continuous eight
Dimensions Define our treatment and this
is also possible and this can be done so
there are models that that can take
multiple or multi-dimensional continuous
treatments and this could be also
generalized to natural language although
I don't know
papers like this I think at this stage
and you got requests
um about like can you send us slides and
some papers to the Discord channel for
example in this A5 E6 so
for how long it will will the Discord be
open
okay so if it stays open I will I will
do it later today otherwise I will add
some more papers so there's there's one
paper but I will add more papers to the
repository that we used for the for the
talk okay
okay
great thank you so much
[Applause]